êtes vous une femme toute casse pas la
tête non non non ce n'est pas une femme
c'est un homme est ce que vous venez
pour une femme non non non jp c'est par
amitié je m'en rappelle la discothèque
j'ai un peu caché à 84
on plaisante mais je sais pas s'il était
spectateur ressente le flip total mais
c'est quoi vous souhaitez pas votre vie
pour être autre convoyeur pour alain les
montagnes aurillac
enterré je ne veux pas que ça revienne
aib a bien vite j'ai tourné le dos à sa
portée
à chacune des équipes de production de
thé pmp sont des équipes complètement
folle et on peut retrouver des choses
incroyables de ma dernière et les
discours si je dis rien oui terminait ce
que vous en avez de quoi des fois le
soir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il en a donc j nous avons de la famille
de quelqu'un
première en dix premiers indices les
amis pour vous aider dans votre
réflexion on regarde
tu reconnais pas le comportement de
votre beauté vous reconnaissez pas de
grain faut maintenant que porto rico
deuxième deux autres questions parlons
cuba avait vous partagez le cigare avec
un des invités
question alors avec mathieu il avait un
vrai talent et un tuba vous non non et
légendes cuba vienne avait rencontré une
cubaine non il est pas cuba cuba
possible voir aussi non alors chez les
autres question style ou alors gilou qui
sont
là je commence à mon doigt s'est
sérieusement s'il ou un baiser cuba vous
il n'en oui oui il connaît très bien
aussi alors
avez vous rencontré quelqu'un sur le
plateau
à la havane
ah là là alors il est pas bien du tout
et l'ambiance du jeu alors est-ce que
gillet ce qu'est ce qu'on ferait pas un
nouvel indice
ça fait longtemps
[Musique]
dubé
les amis
[Musique]
vous l'avez compris visiblement on est
plus de ce côté ci de la table on est
plutôt du côté de cuba way et on est
plutôt vers on s'est donné rendez vous
dans dix ans sans même jouer même heure
même port cjrc les achats d'or par
gilles commence à avoir
ses même pas c'est même pas peur je
pense qu'il commence à avoir de
l'émotion qui vont alors je sens qu'il
est pas voilà est-ce que vous avez des
questions à poser à notre invité mystère
encore une allez-y bon auriez-vous des
rapports dans d'amitié ou des des
rapports familiaux avec quelqu'un sur le
plateau non alors oui ou non
pourquoi rapport à l'amitié des rapports
d'amitié
des rapports d'amitié
gilles à la bouche ouverte et n'arrive
plus à respirer je propose en faire - 2e
les indices
troisième indice
ségolin ça c'est au tour de la star
accroche une prison ce prix les travaux
dit quelque chose dit ou ce troisième a
diffusé un pensionnat via les 80 où l'on
karnas ça vous dit rien veut tout au
long ça vous dit rien mais non ça me dit
rien c'est une école ça veut dire une
école non mais attention elle est la
gueule libératoire c'est lena magali
gerber ce soir il s'agit d'écoles c'est
une question qui l'école à l'internât à
noter encore une université non fac
l'invité mystère arrive immédiatement
regarder l'invité mystère
vas-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gilles où il y hadji de xavier aux
abysses et votre copain depuis le lycée
mais oui dans fonce on a tous connu
ensemble on est allé à amsterdam on a
tous vécu ensemble
était en été et puis à l'époque vous
aviez les cheveux longs mais oui il est
venu à mon mariage à cuba et c'est vrai
qu'on est les lèvera c'est mon meilleur
ami et on s'est perdus de vue
[Applaudissements]
merci d'être là xavier mais recevant de
mon dieu à notre invitation et je sais
que vous aviez vous vous avez dit à nos
équipes quand on a travaillé sur votre
la surprise de gila vous l'avez trouvé
sa chronique et
vous allez viens on s'écrit parfois mais
on se voit pas assez et on s'écrit on
s'écrie un peu pris au téléphone ça fait
combien de temps vous étiez pas vu là un
vrai plusieurs années 1 3 en tête
michael we 4 4 longtemps qu'un accord
5,6
on a fait beaucoup de choses je devais
quand même aller à l'anniversaire de sa
toupie si tu m'a invité et je pouvais
pas nier ce que vous êtes là vous allez
donc pouvoir balancer plein de
mais tout ça
l'eris était comment comme comme élève
en terminale en première et écologie
alors le tiens on lui il était brillant
donc il était en hypokhâgne et c'est moi
j'étais nettement moins bon d'accord je
n'étais pas tout à fait les mêmes
classes et la réponse que vous espériez
des
petites bêtises toutes les bêtises du
monde exemple
c'est la chasse et moi ça
était beau
[Rires]
s'être retrouvé à cuba tous les deux
d'abord et ben parce que sa vie fait
partie des quelques personnes d'ici qui
sont à l'air mon mariage à cuba moi je
me suis marié
la maman de ma fille et de la femme elle
vit aujourd'hui en france elle est
française mais les cubaines et xavier
venu au mariage alors pour les 400 coups
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'on vivait dans
l'essonne à 5 min sur orge et un au plus
grand truc c'était de se balader nu la
nuit dans les rues de sa mission
mais comme ça par pur plaisir
parce que votre corps méritait d'être
nue c'est ça mon corps ne concordent
accorde à des images
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quand on veut nous raconter un tout
petit peu parce emblème le mariage de
gilles comment ça s'était passé le suit
comme nous on attend le mariage avec
fatou au moins qu on ait un premier
comment j'ai dit oui quand même alors j
c'est un gars qui a totalement généreux
d'avant et ce mariage en fait ça a été
un truc de dingue parce que il y était
en fête avec son envie de générosité
donner quelque chose et avaient tous
couverts mariage ailleurs est au plus
bas et un puce son idée c'était quand
même de faire sortir cette fille de la
dictature cubaine et de l'amener vers la
liberté on peut le dire comme ça ah
ouais donc vous vous êtes mariés et vous
avez pu ramener un autre a légalisé il
ya eu des enquêtes ça a été un truc de
dingue on a fait faire bref mais il ya
eu des enquêtes des autorités cubaines
et françaises pour savoir si tout était
normal
c'était une aventure un film
d'espionnage et xavière participé à tout
ça il a aidé grandement c'est une très
belle histoire
et bien évidemment de l'ampleur que vous
êtes enceinte vous allez vous allez
dîner après l'émission tous les deux
chez léo fred sarre il je balance comme
il est pas là j'étais au fond de la
scène security régal allez hop soyons
fous si le beau cadeau avec grand
plaisir ça me fait plaisir de rentrer
[Applaudissements]
m